welcome everybody to this webinar on
saving and investment strategies for
long-term financial planning
particularly for retirement my name is
josh rau those of you who have been
taking my massive open online course my
mooc on the finance of retirement and
pensions already uh know me some of you
i want to welcome my students to this
webinar very much looking forward to
your participation i'll tell you in a
moment how you can participate and also
to welcome everybody uh everyone who
might be watching this uh around the u.s
and around the world and invite you to
participate in this very exciting
webinar we're gonna be talking today
about the uh you know the strategies for
long-term financial planning saving an
investment particularly when you're
thinking about a strategy for saving for
retirement talk a little bit about some
of the conventional wisdom and we'll be
asking whether that conventional wisdom
is right for everybody or not
so welcome to all i'm really excited
today about the panel that we have here
with us today i have three very esteemed
guests i'd like to introduce them
introduce them now so the first guest
with me here is uh william sharp bill
sharp the stanco 25 emeritus professor
of finance at the stanford graduate
school of business welcome bill
bill has a phd
and a master's degree and a bachelor's
degree in economics from ucla so he did
all of his education at ucla he joined
the faculty here at stanford in 1970 and
in 1990 he received the nobel prize in
economic sciences he is one of the
originators of the capital asset pricing
model a model that will be familiar to
my students and he also developed the
sharp ratio for investment performance
analysis named after him he's published
articles in every possible professional
journal he's written several books
including portfolio theory and capital
markets and we're delighted to have him
with us here today
my second guest is john americs now john
americs is a principal and head of
active equity
research at the vanguard equity
investment group his team manages or
co-manages vanguard's active stock funds
using quantitative methods
vanguard as many of you know is a mutual
fund firm an investment firm with around
two trillion dollars in assets
they provide mutual funds and
exchange-traded funds have been done
doing mutual funds since 1929 he's also
done a a great amount of academic
research published in top journals so
welcome john delighted to have you here
john americs
uh and my third guest today is john
koniff john knife is a managing director
and quantitative portfolio manager for
the tiaa cref organization since 2006
tiaa cref was founded in 1918 and it's
also an investment firm they specialize
in the needs of non-profit organizations
and their employees john knife was
previously the director of u.s research
at morgan stanley investment management
and has been a portfolio manager at
several other investment firms so
welcome to uh to my entire panel and
thank you all very much for being here
now i'd like to uh call your attention
to some of the features of this uh of of
of this webinar today so first we have
uh a twitter feed and i encourage you to
tweet in any questions that you might
have or any comments that you might have
about this about this webinar and that
includes questions and comments that you
would like me to
ask our panel so the hashtag for this is
going to be rao finance so hashtag rao
finance that's my last name and finance
all one word and please feel free to use
twitter and get the social media buzzing
about
this exciting webinar today another way
i'd like to invite you to participate is
through some polls and survey questions
that i'm going to be asking you and
we've designed four poll questions for
you that you're going to be able to
answer and to i'm very interested in
hearing what what your answers are to
these questions and when i have the
results uh i'm going to be telling you
about the audience here today what
you've answered and what the uh what the
distribution of responses has been so
let me walk you through what the
questions are the first question is in
how many years you plan to retire and
you can either say i don't know or you
can say a range of dates or you can say
you never plan to retire
the second question is going to be what
percentage of your 401 k or you can also
answer this you know if you have other
employer-provided defined contribution
funds what percentage of those funds are
invested in stocks or equity mutual
funds so i'm interested in how much
stock market investing you all are doing
so i think that'll be a very interesting
question the third question i'd like you
to talk about uh answer yes or no is do
you think this is an opinion question do
you think that stocks are safer in the
long run than they are in the short run
yes no or i don't know that's a question
for you and the fourth question is uh
whether you have reduced or do you plan
to reduce your exposure to stocks in
your 401k or other defined contribution
retirement account as you approach
retirement yes or no so i'm very much
looking forward to uh seeing your
responses to this uh to these survey
questions and to presenting you with the
uh the distribution of responses that
this wonderful viewership here gives
well with that i'd like to uh
jump right in and turn to the themes for
today and start right out by asking my
panel uh the first question that i had
which is uh really i wanna know uh maybe
uh john americs maybe you can you can
start out with this uh what is the
number one consideration that people
planning doing long-term financial
planning particularly planning for
retirement what is the number one
consideration that they need to be
thinking of
um you need to start saving you need to
get in the plan
very simply uh there are a lot of people
out there with opportunities to save
that they're not taking advantage of and
so i would say the number one thing is
make sure you participate and start
putting something away through the
vehicles available to you mm-hmm
and uh what you know in terms of uh make
sure you're participating what exactly
should people be participating in maybe
you could just be a little more specific
about what what what are the
opportunities absolutely yeah
the the big one that a lot of people
have are 401k plans through their
employer or 403b plans if they're in a
non-profit sector
those plans will allow them to defer
portions of their income and put those
away for the future and invest them and
we'll talk a little bit more about how
they can invest them later mo and
importantly many of those plans feature
what's called an employer match
which essentially
provides an additional incentive for
people to save if you put four percent
of your pay in your employer may match
up to
say an additional four percent
you should definitely take advantage of
that you get an immediate return on your
contributions by doing so free money in
essence if you're able to contribute the
money today then your employer is giving
you free money if you're not then you're
not going to be getting access to those
to those funds no you're not cashing
your paycheck that's what i like to say
you're not cashing your paycheck i like
that uh now uh bill sharp maybe you
could uh say something about about the
following question which is
how can people even begin to think about
how much they need to uh to save you
know where where do they even start i
mean what's
what kind of what kind of rules would
you would you think about uh giving
people guidelines in terms of thinking
about how much they need to save to be
able to be prepared for retirement
well it depends on
sort of the obvious things
how many years you've got before you
plan to or at least hope to retire
how much money you're saving as a
percentage of your salary
and
what you think
you might earn on those investments
understanding
that
in all likelihood that's going to be a
range a distribution as you point out in
the course
so you need to think about all those
issues there are rules of thumb
that if you start at a fairly young age
the total that you and your employer
need to put in as a percent of your
salary is
probably somewhere between 15 and 20 now
that's that's
that's making a lot of assumptions
but uh i think the important thing that
that number is typically larger than
most people
think it is required and you've got to
save a lot
in almost every circumstance
uh
and and so you've got to find a way to
put in
numbers that are in that range and john
can if you you agree with that what do
you what what kinds of savings savings
strategies do you advise for your
clients
yes well
your class earlier on savings for
retirement had
an assignment and you had a 10
contribution rate the employee benefit
research institute in a recent study
showed that the average american is
contributing seven percent
uh of their salary to retirement so
uh as bill sharp uh mentioned those
numbers generally americans generally
need to save more for retirement i
definitely look for opportunities for
company match
and
consider a plan consider retirement
readiness look out many years in the
future or if you're approaching
retirement potentially meet with a
financial advisor
and have a budget for your retirement
and look at how your investments can
match income create income and match
that for your budget
now one one thing i've always found very
interesting i talk to people about about
these uh these issues sometimes people
don't even really know whether they're
saving in a 401k plan or not uh how can
how can that be i mean so if you just
start a job is it uh you maybe talk a
little bit about what what typically
happens to people if they don't take any
action if you take no action uh do is
some money going into an account or not
what how does this typically work uh
john emericks maybe you want to take a
shot at that so
it's a it's a big uh area it's one of
the the areas where i think there's been
a lot of very recent research in the
last 10 to 15 years about this issue of
defaults
what happens to an employee that starts
a new job
are they in the plan to begin with or
not and you know 20 years ago or even 15
years ago the normal situation was you
had to get up and proactively go sign up
for the retirement plan in order to be
in it
and um surprise surprise lots of very
young workers who were in their first
job
uh were not real interested or real
cognizant of these issues around
retirement saving and a lot fewer people
signed up for those plans than i think
most benefits officers most policy
makers would like to have seen
research that's been done by behavioral
economists and others over the years has
shown an incredibly powerful powerful
effect of just flipping the default on
its head
auto enrolling people into a plan
and that will get people to save it will
solve the first problem that i told you
needed to be solved it gets someone in
the plan and saving
uh but it can raise other issues as you
mentioned of people not being aware of
of what's going on but um you know
that's ultimately you've got to get
involved you've got to get engaged to
understand what's happening with your
retirement money and it's very important
to do so as young as you can so if i
might just sort of summarize just
something we've heard you know uh for
those of you out there i mean it may be
that you're watching this and you're
thinking well what what exactly is is
going on am i contributing to my own
retirement fund right now or not um you
may not remember what you did when you
signed up for your job you may not
remember how much money is going in
there and it might be useful to
especially uh you know those of you who
are students in the in the open online
course you know we've done these kind of
this kind of spreadsheet modeling it
might be useful for you to compare what
it is you know go look up what what is
it you're actually doing are you are you
really contributing to your to your 401k
or not how much money is going in there
every month and and is it likely to to
be sufficient by the way as i'm
mentioning the mooc uh one thing i did
want to do is i wanted to just invite
all viewers uh even if you just tuned in
just for this webinar to feel free to
check out the mooc
the link to the mooc is available online
it's uh it's uh it's available you can
see the same link that you found uh this
uh this webinar at you can also find the
link to the uh to the to the mooc
and if you you know anyone is welcome
it's not too late to sign up feel free
to just uh sign up and uh check out all
the interesting things that were that
were that we're doing there uh the the
url is is www.novoed.com
row dash finance
so inviting everybody to uh feel free to
to check that out
so going back to uh the panel now just a
couple of other issues about uh about
saving i want to talk about before we we
move on to uh to investing to asset
allocation and one big question i was
wondering about is it seems like people
are increasingly
kind of
doing things to try to access their
money from their 401k before the time
that they're actually uh retired um
anybody want to maybe bill sharp you
want to talk a little bit about about
about that i mean
do do people uh you know borrow from
their 401ks is that a good idea to be
borrowing money from your 401k to try to
move consumption forward
uh i would say
as a general rule probably not a good
idea
there are obviously circumstances
in which it may be necessary if there's
a emergency need for funds
but
since
the major problem that we see is that
people don't seem to be saving enough
uh if you borrow that is therefore less
unless you pay it back and
that that may be
questionable whether you will or not
then there are all kinds of tax issues
which i can't say i fully understand but
i think we should we should
be negative about borrowing uh absent a
really really compelling reason i
believe in most cases if you lose your
job or you quit you owe the money back
is that is that right uh americs do i
understand that question
it that is a feature of the 401k system
for sure
i believe the rules are slightly
different for different types of plans
but for most people that are in the
private sector that's going to be an
issue that's one of the things you
really should worry about if you don't
know
whether you're required to pay it back
when you lose your job or when you
change jobs you should ask at the time
you go to to get the loan
well now what what about people who are
uh approaching retirement actually i was
looking at some of the uh survey results
the distribution of uh your responses uh
to the question not from uh today but
the question in the mooc uh about how
many years away you are from retirement
i noticed that there is definitely a
massive of people in this course who are
zero to 10 years before retirement and i
imagine that some of you if you've been
taking this course you might have
actually taken a look at your own
accounts and some people may have seen
well gee actually it seems like i have
this kind of hodgepodge of accounts from
old jobs you know i have a 401k from
this job and i have uh i have an ira
here a roth ira here um you know
actually i'll stick with you john
americs i mean what what do you advise
people to do who are say zero to ten
years away from retirement you know
getting getting close and they have this
kind of hodgepodge of accounts out there
what what do you have any advice for for
those people
well i you know i think uh the
hodgepodge by itself um it doesn't
necessarily create a problem i want to
be you want to be clear about that um we
we would argue as well as most other
financial services companies that
consolidating your assets uh you know
allows you a lot of convenience
um you know it it is harder to manage
when you have a lot of things in
different places
um but the bottom line is if you've got
to look at all of that together and if
it constitutes a diversified portfolio
it may not necessarily uh be be a
problem so so by consolidating you mean
maybe rolling over into a traditional
ira or even perhaps a roth ira
right that's correct and that there are
awful lot of tax issues to tax and
other other
legal issues
that you need to sort through there are
trade-offs to be made when you make
those those rollovers and it may be one
of those areas where especially for
people close to retirement
john john c's advice about talking to an
advisor to work through some of these
things gets increasingly important
especially if there's company stock
in a 401k plan because that's subject to
special treatment according to the tax
laws that you probably ought to think
about company stock in a 401 k plan well
that gets to uh the next kind of general
set of topics i want to discuss which is
uh investment strategies in 401k plans
and you know many of you are probably
thinking okay i get the message we need
to save a lot and all right so another
way if let's suppose we've kind of
optimized this saving uh what you know
what should we be investing in now uh
john amrex you just alluded to the idea
that there are a lot of people out there
who are investing uh in companies stock
uh the stock of their of their own
company uh you know actually i want to
turn to bill sharp a little bit about
this since bill is one of the founders
of modern finance theory i mean what
does modern finance theory tell us about
whether you should be investing in your
own company's stock or not
um simple answer bad idea
the uh
the argument is that in
many situations if not
not all certainly but most um
there's plenty of company specific risk
in your job in your employment if things
go bad in your company or in your
industry uh your job may be jeopardized
you may have to suffer a cutback in
salary or hours what have you
so the last thing you want to do is add
to that specific risk the basic mantra
of being widely diversified
uh would argue that when you take the
human capital into account uh you've got
a concentration of some sort depending
on your
job uh
company specific risk so
adding to that by holding company stock
is not a good idea there's a tension
here because many companies want
employees to have company stock give
them incentives to work harder and be
more devoted to the company there's a
tension between what might be good from
a company
policy standpoint and what is good from
a strictly investment standpoint but by
and large
a lot of people in the investment
industry would say
10 or under you know absent compelling
reason keep it down in the single digits
if you must do it at all
i mean in essence you know your eggs are
sort of already in that basket and by
investing in company stock you're
putting more eggs in the basket in that
same basket and your eggs are already in
the basket because your financial future
depends upon how well you know how
whether you get to keep your job and do
you really want to also be investing in
the stock of a company that's going to
be deciding whether you keep your job or
not especially since the fortunes of
that company will determine whether or
not you keep your job there are some
historically there are some very tragic
cases ibm went into a tailspin at one
point
and many of their executives have their
entire retirement savings in company
stock
uh and there have been other cases of
that store i don't think that happens as
much anymore
most 401k plans are cognizant of this
issue and they tend not to encourage
people to have huge concentrations in
company stock but it's something to
watch out for um definitely a
red flag um well i want to talk now just
about more generally about investment
strategies so let's suppose that uh you
know you've reached the point where
you've sort of optimized your savings
strategy and you're you're saving as
much as you can you're taking advantage
of employer matches uh what about the
investment side of things you know how
should you actually allocate these
assets and i just want to turn to to to
john kniff of taa cref and just ask him
uh john you know what would you advise
is just kind of the general investment
strategy for people i mean where do you
start i imagine some of our viewers are
probably they're probably at this point
you know kind of scrambling around their
laptop looking at their portfolios and
thinking oh my gosh what a mess what am
i doing here what can you just give us
just some general advice about about
about how asset allocation should be
looking uh for younger people middle
aged people people approaching
retirement what do you think
sure well here at tia cref i manage the
ti craft life cycle funds now what is
that by the way life cycle funds a life
cycle fund is a series of target
retirement date portfolios for example
here we have a life cycle 2055 fund
which is for someone who's young and has
more than 40 years ahead of them and
will plan to retire in 2055 and we have
funds every five years through 2010 and
also a retirement income fund
the portfolios are designed with an
asset allocation that glides appropriate
for your years to retirement
they start aggressive with high
allocations to stocks and then as you
approach retirement become more
conservative
and have more allocations to bonds the
investment thesis behind lifecycle funds
in general are a human capital financial
capital model and as bill chart
mentioned with human capital when you're
young you have many years ahead of you
to be able to contribute
and invest in your savings so you have a
large position in human capital and
hence your financial capital can be very
aggressive when you're young when you
approach retirement and in retirement
you need to have a more balanced
portfolio a more conservative portfolio
with more allocation to bonds so life
cycle funds are used today as the auto
enroll it's it's very important to
emphasize that anyone currently
investing in a lifecycle fund or
considering it you should look at the
prospectus and the material at the
company's website each glide path is a
little different and you should be aware
of what you're investing in and it's
also important that lifecycle funds
don't guarantee an income or capital
value that if you want to go in that
direction we could talk later about
annuities
and i think you know life cycle funds i
mean they're they're undertaking a more
sophisticated investment strategy for
you by you know by rebalancing towards
safer securities as the investor gets
close to retirement and you know for
that you're going to see you know the
fees on lifecycle funds being somewhat
higher than the fees on index funds but
that you know that's sort of a service
you're paying for it so you got to you
got to take a look and and see how you
you you view that view that that
trade-off you can also uh you know those
who are not in lifecycle funds you can
also consider doing some of that
rebalancing on your on your own um now i
think uh one a very interesting uh topic
we've kind of been touching on here is
that uh you know you can think think
about the household balance sheet is
consisting of both financial capital and
also human capital and so by financial
capital we mean whatever stocks or bonds
or savings you might have and by by
human capital we mean the fact that your
your your labor income you know your
earnings your your like your lifetime
earnings those are the fact that you own
this sort of stock of whatever it is
skills or education or something that
kind of allows you to earn money over
the course of years and i i guess uh you
know one interesting question i'll pose
uh maybe uh john america could you could
take this up a little bit is uh you know
how does how does uh say the optimal
investment strategy of somebody who has
got a really really safe uh stream of
labor income uh that is sort of not you
know not really volatile or moving
around the stock market how does that
investment strategy compare to maybe the
investment strategy of somebody who's
whose life's lifetime earnings are
essentially going to rise and fall with
the fortunes of you know the stock
market or the u.s economy do you have
any different recommendations for those
kinds of people or
well sure i mean i don't know whether
it's a recommendation but it is a
conclusion that comes out of the type of
modeling uh that we do that sort of
posits rational behavior and
well-defined preferences over risk
and in that kind of a world
uh the correlation patterns that you're
talking about in the one situation a
very safe or secure future income stream
a college professor let's say um
although you have to decide whether the
business school is the safest portion of
the uh
the professorship but uh you know one
with tenure
there's an income there that's uh very
very solid and perhaps that means you
can afford to take a little bit more
risk with your financial investments
on the other hand
someone who's working uh in the finance
industry who's
whose uh human capital paycheck and
certainly bonus payments may be
correlated with what happens in the
equity markets
might want to think very carefully about
exactly how much uh how much of their
eggs they want to put in that basket
it's sort of a very similar problem
to the company stock problem just sort
of one step removed now company stock is
very specifically tied to your human
capital now we're kind of talking about
relationships that are a little fuzzier
and there's room to move around around
the edges um you know in general
estimating those correlations over very
long periods of time is very very tricky
business uh
for sure now bill sharp what what do you
think about life cycle funds and the
strategy of of life cycle and you know
life cycle investing where uh you want
to invest in the target date funds such
as the ones described by john kniff
where are where the you know the
investors are getting rebalanced towards
something that's less risky as the
investors approach uh retirement what
what do you think of those of those
strategies and how do they uh you know
how do they tie in with the sort of with
the economic theory uh surrounding asset
allocation
well i think as as as both john said
the the best rationale for what's called
the glide path
start out with a relatively high part
number portion in stocks glide down to
lower portions
rationalization or rationale for that is
the human capital argument
as when you when you're young
the present value if you will of your
future savings from your earnings is
large and your financial capital is
small
so you need to sort of think about the
risk and return of the totality
and as you
go closer to retirement those
proportions change and so to keep if you
will the same
overall risk and return you need to
rebalance along some sort of glide path
um two things i think are important to
point out
the
target date funds or life cycle funds
are designed
with
some notion of a quote average investor
in mind average in terms of your
profession and it's worth
average in terms of your risk tolerance
what have you um so if you differ from
the average you're more willing to take
risk or you have a different profession
then that means you have to either do
something different or maybe find a life
cycle fund that's designed for somebody
older or younger than you are the other
thing i'd point out
the argument for a glide path
increasing conservatism
to the extent it's based on human
capital falls away when you retire and
we see some
funds that continue to do the the segway
post retirement i i'm a little bit
stressed trying to figure out you know
what the rationale for that is and then
the final point i would i would point
out is that um when you look at funds
for people retiring in let's say 2035
across different
financial providers they differ
considerably
and of course in any given period their
performance will differ considerably so
it's not as if there is an agreed upon
notion of what that average investor
situation is
so there are different funds that take
somewhat different views even about the
average investor so there are a lot of
uncertainties there
that said the basic premise is i think
good up to retirement
yeah and i think it's also worth
emphasizing that you know different life
cycle funds are going to be uh
rebalancing you towards you know
different actual investments so some
will go more heavily into longer term
nominal treasury bonds some into shorter
term treasury bonds some into tips
treasury inflation protected securities
which are protected against increases in
inflation some into cash uh maybe some
into other things so it seems worthwhile
if you're going to investigate these
products to really look at what they're
rebalancing into and consider the risks
of those investments as well you know i
i think if your horizon is short then
you know long-term treasury bonds you
know they carry some risks
and before but unless we leave it as
you've emphasized over and over again
expense ratios expense ratios expense
ratios critical critical what the actual
fees and expenses are i'd like to bring
in a tweet actually that we've we've
come
from phil geller at working max uh he's
tweeted in retirement how do you go
about spending down a diversified
portfolio what do you sell off first and
uh and what do you what do you retain
and that's very good timing because i
was just thinking about trying to to get
to some of those ideas uh what what do
you do if you you reach retirement and
you say i i've done my best now i have
this this this nest egg or this balance
uh what what what should i what should i
do uh maybe john knife do you want to
take a shot at that one uh
sure
uh
yes well
as i mentioned before meeting with a
financial advisor looking at retirement
readiness
you can have a budget for retirement and
then you have different possible sources
of income you have social security
potentially 401k savings that you can
draw down potentially a defined benefit
plan annuities or other savings
and there's tax consequences as well so
each person's situation is different
uh you you did have i noticed a paper
that you attached with
different rates and some financial
advisors historically uh have talked
about a four percent drawdown rate so
there's a range but it'll differ based
upon your asset allocation your time
horizon your expected returns there's a
lot of math there uh and assumptions in
each person's situation is unique
john emericks what would you add to that
yeah so i those those things are right
and new try to be a little bit more um
represented a lot of the research the
four four percent rule i think that that
comes out of a variety of different
places and
i know bill and i have interacted over
the years and and talked a little bit
about uh where this comes from
um there's a lot of problems with some
of the analysis that's done but bottom
line is for someone who's got a sort of
endowment-like view of what they're
trying to do with their assets they're
really not trying to spend it down
aggressively they're trying to draw
some portion uh spend in some way some
systematic way from their portfolio
you know you can there are very large uh
endowments around the world that will
use that kind of a four percent rate of
of drawdown assumption so it's not
unreasonable
that said
um all the considerations that john's
brought up are very very important there
are some people who really are looking
to spend they saved spent their
lifetimes they took our advice
accumulated large amounts of money and
now it's time to spend it
how do i spend it so that i am actually
dipping into principle and running the
balance down in such a way that it lasts
as long as i want it to
it'll get complicated depending on time
horizon and and uh what what people are
investing are invested in so the first
step is sort of understanding what your
objectives are for your retirement money
and when i when i look at uh you know
the typical retirement dates and i look
at expected returns in the stock market
and the distributions of outcomes that
one can expect in stock markets four
percent seems like a pretty aggressive
spend down at least in
in in today in today's environment it
depends obviously when you retire right
how many years you expect this to last
uh but it might be might be somewhat
regret somewhat aggressive that brings
me to the other thing that you know
we've discussed a lot in the class is of
course annuities and uh obviously as
those who have been taking the mooc know
you know annuities are an interesting
financial product that provides uh
longevity insurance and that is sort of
insurance against living a long time
usually we think if you live a long time
hey that's a great thing i lived a long
time but it's not such a great thing if
you outlive all of your resources
so maybe uh some of you on the panel
could speak to that what do you think
the role is of life annuities in
investor portfolios and i want to be
clear that here i'm talking about sort
of fairly plain vanilla life annuities i
mean there's a whole range of annuity
products that use the word annuity but
i'm talking about just a product where
an investor you know gives a an amount
of money up front to uh to the the
provider of the annuity insurance
company or investment firm and that firm
promises them a guaranteed income uh for
life what do you think the roles of that
would be in investor portfolios i'll
leave any one of you who wants to grab
that one to grab it
bill sharp
right
well i think
you know one of the great mysteries and
you've alluded to it in the course
is that
our procedures for
supplemental saving supplemental to
social security or for years in the u.s
the fine benefit which is that you turn
it out it's an annuity you pay in and
then you take out until you die or your
spouse dies what have you
um we went to a defined contribution
regime
which could have a defined contribution
plan could provide annuities in the plan
you could take your lump sum out at the
end and buy an annuity and almost nobody
does i mean it's like maybe 10 percent
of
some number in that range of the dc
money every time it is annuitized
so there's been this tectonic shift
away from
using your savings
to buy
assured income till you die
to
games and there are a million schemes
and there's no four percent rule that
you mentioned and there's no settled
agreement in the industry or certainly
an academe on the desirability of this
scheme or that scheme for this person or
that person that's an area of incredible
turmoil at the moment but i think
annuities
are
fine you know if you're very rich why
why bother you know you're happy to have
large amounts of your wealth go to your
kids or your charities but for people
who are close to it where the social
security annuity
is not enough
and they really aren't in a position to
take much risk with the remainder or
plan to leave a lot to their heirs
i think annuities are extremely sensible
uh
ways to
take care of your post-retirement needs
but for a number of reasons some
behavioral some otherwise perhaps we
don't see a lot of voluntary
annuitization which concerns me
yeah it's interesting because i think a
lot of people
get to retirement they say okay what
should i do then they think about maybe
buying an annuity and look at the rates
and they say gee you know i'm gonna fork
over a hundred thousand dollars this
point i'm only gonna get paid 400 500 a
month that's a frightening proposition
to uh to to a lot of people and it also
raises the idea of products that might
actually uh kind of default you into
some annuitization before i know john
conniff you know tiaa-cref has a long
history of providing uh products that
have an annuity feature with them i
don't you want to say any words about
those the role of those people yeah we
yes here at tia correct we have a very
long history with annuities our tiaa
traditional count dates back to 1918 our
crest stock account dates back to 1952.
it's the first variable annuity in
america
and a benefit that tia offers is that
in our plans and many of our plans you
have the opportunity during your working
years to contribute to annuity and that
seems from a behavioral point of view as
bill sharp was mentioning that that can
help people stay in annuity through
retirement and annuities provide
guaranteed income
for years in retirement or potentially
your lifetime there's at least two types
of annuity a fixed annuity that'll
provide a guaranteed income for a period
of time and then also variable annuities
which could provide higher income but
have exposure to the stock market as
well so that can vary i mean that's the
way i think about these products you can
correct me if i'm if i'm if i'm wrong
the way i think about them is during the
working life you know an individual is
basically accruing you know rights to
receive an annuity when he or she
retires and that if that's a fixed you
know fixed deferred annuity that amount
is going to be uh not a function of how
the stock market does or other assets
that things are invested in if it's uh
if it's a variable annuity then it is
going to be a a function of the
of the stock market john emericks what
would you want to weigh in here a little
bit on the this question of annuities
life annuities fixed activities deferred
annuities variable annuities
i'd love to and probably your class
doesn't have enough time to hear
everything i have to say about it it's a
it's been an area of active academic
research for me for about 15 years
thinking about you know why why do
people choose annuities why don't they
um you know i view them very much as
very useful to provide a floor of income
you know they do for retirees provide
someone with the ability to know you
know how much will i have as a base for
my income going forward you think about
social security we think about defined
benefit pensions as forms of annuities
many many people have those um by far
the most fascinating thing to me is that
where we where
auto enrollment as i mentioned earlier
and life cycle funds
when those are used as default options
in retirement savings plans the rates at
which people reject those defaults are
very small most people go along with
that they enter into the plan they save
they also seem to go along with and be
happy with the glide paths that we've
talked about
the one big difference about annuities
at the point of retirement is people
seem to actively want to
there is active de-annuitization going
on so a couple of different forms people
retiring with defined benefit plan
entitlements
that that the default payout is an
annuity will elect to take a cash
payment instead
the other thing is many retirement plan
participants
uh when looking at their assets and are
in a form of a plan that requires
annuitization will take a spouse to a
notary public
in order to get a permission to take the
money out of the plan as a lump sum so
the behavioral issues are very complex
and i think it relates to thinking about
retirement security in a very very
different way maybe than we have
traditionally
income is very very important we need to
have some but there are expenditures and
events that happen in retirement that
are not
linear in nature that are not you can't
buy insurance for them you can't know
that it's going to cost you x dollars a
year for the rest of your life
to deal with long-term care necessarily
and you know those types of risks um or
what i'm currently studying trying to
find out whether as bill mentioned
is this irrational is this people saying
irrationally that i can do better and i
don't have to worry about longevity risk
or is it something that's a little bit
more reasonable and rational that no i i
can't predict what my situation's going
to be in 20 years i want to maximize
flexibility and i need liquid assets to
do that we don't know the answers right
now the answer we know the answer so
yeah i'd like to uh turn and take
another tweet i'm also looking forward
in a minute to getting the poll results
um so let's take another tweeted
question uh from ichen chang uh
i-e-c-h-e-n are financial advisors worth
it at one percent
uh most don't want you unless you have a
million dollars how do you get there in
the meantime anybody want to want to
talk to that speak to that
bill sharp please professor
well
we are seeing the growth of online
uh lower cost
quote financial advice
uh at this point is
very highly varied quality but uh as you
point out in the in the uh in the course
one percent is a big chunk if you're
you know if you're going to take say
four percent out and your advisor is
going to take another one
in in some ways you're losing one fifth
one percent divided by four plus one uh
which is a huge huge hit now vanguard
has tools that can show you this in the
accumulation phase
but uh you better be getting an awful
lot if you're paying one percent a year
every year during your retirement
so there needs to be some way and there
are there are other procedures sometimes
through your employer you can get what
amounts to a tailored uh procedure post
retirement as well but we need to bring
the costs down
significantly that's just too much
well i want to actually go over some of
these survey results if we've got them
be great to be able to uh tell you how
people answered the uh answer the survey
um so in how many years do you plan to
retire of our viewership
it turns out that about 25 of you are
retired only three percent of you do not
plan to retire 11 of you have got 30 or
more years through retirement uh and
around a quarter of you have got 10 to
30 years to retirement and 34 of you
have zero to ten so some uh three four
percent of zero to ten so i would say
and we had we had uh over 1500 votes
here so i i would say uh there's
definitely a um uh
a lot of people are getting close to
retirement who are who are thinking
about these issues um we have the other
questions up there it'd be great to see
those what percentage of your 401k do
you invest in stocks or equity mutual
funds so this is great we got a a great
distribution here so we've got about 10
percent of you invest less than 20
percent 8 20 to 40 percent and then a
lot of people uh you know around 30
percent investing uh 40 to 60 60 80 and
80 to 100 so a fair number of uh stock
investors here um the next question was
related to whether you think stocks are
safer in the long run than they are in
the short run and 74 of our of our
viewers said that stocks are safer in
the long run than in the short run uh
and 17 said no 9 said i don't know now
before i go to that last question uh
which was about life cycle strategies i
just like somebody on the panel maybe
maybe uh john americs could speak a
little bit to uh this question of
whether stocks are safer in the long run
in the short run because there
definitely seems to be a view out there
that uh that they are what do you think
of that
well you know i think this this again is
you know the way you ask the question in
terms of safer we know that um in the
mathematical sense
uh based on the studies that the the
risks that people face even though
stocks
will appear to have high rates of return
with low
volatilities around the annual averages
over long periods of time
you can still
save for 25 years and get to a point in
2008 where you've seen above average
returns for most of your lifetime and in
a course of a few short months lose lose
half of that so
uh you know i would be very careful with
the notion that stocks are safer
uh in in the long term in that sense
um however you know the life cycle
considerations that we've talked about
if you think about the answer to that
question are they safer for me as a
young investor than as an older investor
um
you know because of the flexibilities
that human capital provides
uh they can they can make a little bit
more sense for younger investors than
for older investors but it shouldn't be
interpreted as a safety of the
investment option itself i have to go to
bill sharpe i have to go to bill sharpe
and ask him what he thinks is one of the
founders of finance theory i need to
need to ask you bill
as you tell you this statement has
driven me crazy for 50 years and that's
5-0
it comes from
a really
misleading kind of analysis in which you
say what is the average or the geometric
term return we've talked about over 100
years versus 50 versus 10. here's the
simple
idea put a hundred dollars in stocks
today
look at the range of how much you would
have in one year
and look at the bad part of that you
know
how bad could it be look at think about
putting a hundred dollars in stocks
today and waiting ten years
and look at how bad it could be in ten
years how much money you would have
it could be a lot worse if you hold for
ten years and if you hold for one year
and that is and even if there's mean
reversion and some of the other things
you've talked about that's just a fact
the idea that you look at something
called the geometric gene return or the
arithmetic immune return is basically
irrelevant in terms of what matters for
risk is how bad could it be
um the worst outcome or the ten percent
worst outcome whatever so in no
important
serious sense economic sense personal
sense
is it true that stocks are less risky in
the long run
very interesting i i i concur and i just
like to you know we're pretty much at
our time but i'd like to wrap up a
little bit i just want to do this one
last question have you reduced or do you
plan to reduce your exposure to stocks
in your 401k as you approach retirement
and 62 percent of you said yes 38 of you
said no so 62 of you are sort of
following this uh life cycle portfolio
theory 38 have said no of course you
also might if you're invested in target
date funds you might not be aware uh
whether you've done it or not so uh
those target day funds are actually
rebalancing you uh out of stocks um so
very interesting to see that some people
are some people aren't perhaps those
people who uh uh who are not have
different investment goals they have
different uh maybe they've got a longer
time horizon perhaps
it's the case that they're hoping to
leave some money to their to their
beneficiaries um so i guess i'll uh ask
one more tweet question and then we'll
wrap it up if that would be possible um
so someone has asked patty eisenhower
has asked as some of us near retirement
in 10 years
are investments like bond funds really
less risky than stock mutual funds so
what about bond funds are they are
are they less risky than in that case
are they really less risky uh who wants
to take a stab at that one maybe john
kniff would you like to take a stab at
that one sure yeah i'm very glad well
there's a lot of financial risk as you
approach retirement there's market risk
inflation risk and longevity risk i mean
one way to offset market risk which is
you invest in stocks they may fall and
be volatile is to invest in bonds yields
currently are low
but
they do pay coupons yields
will most likely gradually rise over
time
uh and that that will eat something into
the return there
but over a long period of time they do
provide less volatility can offset
market risk inflation risk could be
offset with investments in
inflation-linked bonds or indirectly
through stocks and longevity risk
risk of outliving your savings generally
consider an annuity
all right well i think it's time that
we've wrapped up our at the end of our
time here i want to thank you all for
participating great thanks participating
in the surveys thanks those who tweeted
it i'm sorry we didn't get to every
tweet today
but looking forward to doing one of
these webinars again with you all in the
future those of you who are not in the
mooc feel free to check out the mooc
those who are in the mooc thank you very
much for your participation i hope that
you're getting something out of it and
looking forward to your continued
participation in the discussion forums
so thank you very much to everybody and
have a great evening